digamos que tenemos aquí el número 5 y
nos preguntamos qué el número debemos
agregar para tener como resultado un 0
yo ya sé la respuesta pero vamos a
dibujarla usando una recta numérica voy
a dibujar la recta numérica así
y voy a posicionar el cero aquí en medio
y el 5 en esta sección en esta parte nos
encontramos en el 5 es el valor que
tenemos actualmente para llegar de aquí
al 0 vamos a tener que recorrer 5
lugares hacia la izquierda a partir del
5 a partir del 5 5 lugares hacia la
izquierda para llegar a este punto al 0
así que este es un -5 por lo que a este
5 le vamos a agregar un -5 para tener
como resultado un cero
es probable que ustedes ya supieran esto
quizás les parezca muy obvio pero se
define con un término muy elegante y
vamos a escribirlo aunque no tengo idea
de por qué nombraron así a esta
propiedad se llama
propiedad
piedad
inversa
la
de la suma
y es sólo la idea de que si tenemos un
número al agregar el inverso del mismo
número tendremos como resultado un ser
por ejemplo si tenemos en esta otra
recta numérica
en donde aquí pongo al cero y tengo un
-3 si comenzamos en menos tres pues ya
movimos tres lugares a la izquierda y
alguien dice bueno que tenemos que
agregar al menos tres para llegar de
vuelta al cero
- 3 la pregunta es menos 3 que le tengo
que agregar a este menos 3 para que mi
resultado sea igual a 0 pues tendremos
que movernos 3 lugares a la derecha a
partir de aquí tendremos que movernos 3
lugares
esto significa que es un 3 por lo que a
este menos 3 si le agregamos un 3 el
resultado va a ser igual a 0
era este lugar de nuestra incógnita así
que en general si tenemos cualquier
número no sé cómo 1.725.000 314
si tenemos este número y se pregunta en
qué número hay que agregar para que esto
sea cero pues tendremos que ir en la
dirección contraria en este caso iremos
hacia la izquierda ya que este es un
número positivo ya la izquierda vamos a
tener los números negativos vamos a
sumar el aditivo inverso por lo que a
esto le voy a sumar su inverso que es
menos 1.725.000 314
todo esto me dará como resultado igual a
cero
de manera similar si tengo un -7 pues
tendré que moverme siete lugares a la
derecha por lo que esto significa
agregar 7
con lo que tendré como resultado será y
creo que con esto ha quedado bien
explicado cuál es la propiedad inversa
de la suma